gut zweieinhalb wochen ist es her dass
die russischen besatzer aus den vororten
von kiew abgezogen sind und sie
hinterließen
verwüstungen und auch bilder des grauens
die stadt butscher ist zum symbol für
die mutmaßlich russischen gräueltaten im
krieg gegen die ukraine geworden und für
uns journalisten und journalistinnen
gilt man muss nicht immer alles an
bildern zeigen nur weil man sie hat weil
wir aber gleich auch darüber reden
werden zeigen wir ihnen diese bilder
jetzt noch einmal wehrlose zivilisten
die offenbar auf offener straße
erschossen wurden zum teil mit den
händen auf den rücken gefesselt
vermutlich grauenhafte beweise dafür
dass es putin nicht nur um militärische
ziele geht forensiker des
internationalen strafgerichtshof haben
leichen aus massengräbern geborgen und
ermitteln zu möglichen kriegsverbrechen
auch die menschenrechtsorganisation
human rights watch hat untersuchungen
durchgeführt betroffene und augenzeugen
auch befragt und live aus kiew
zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt bei kist
wille sie ist mitarbeiterin im krisen
team von human rights watch einen
schönen guten morgen frau wille
guten morgen was können sie uns über den
aktuellen stand ihrer untersuchungen
sagen was sind ihre bisherigen
ergebnisse
erst muss ich einmal sagen dass wir die
leichen noch nicht alle untersuchen
konnten in butter
gemäß den angaben der behörden wissen
wir dass mindestens 300 leichen geborgen
wurden und die ergebnisse die ich heute
erst mit ihnen teilen kann sind nur ein
bruchteil von dem was er tatsächlich
geschehen ist aber wir als organisation
konnten bis jetzt schon einmal 16 fälle
genauer untersuchen darunter sind neun
fälle von willkürlichen hinrichtungen
und zusätzlich auch noch
wahlloses töten von zivilisten und in
dieser ermittlungen die wir durchführen
sind sehr methodisch
haben bis jetzt mit 37 zeugen und opfern
mit medizinischen mitarbeitern
gesprochen vertreter innen von behörden
und denjenigen die
bis jetzt schon mehrfach besucht haben
über ihre methoden wollen wir gleich
auch noch ausführlicher sprechen
vielleicht noch mal kurz nachgefragt die
russische propaganda hat ja immer wieder
behauptet es handele sich um eine
inszenierung ist aus ihrer sicht diese
russische these vollständig widerlegt
aus meiner sicht haben wir das
vollständig widerlegt wir haben die
leiche selbst gesehen wir haben
blutspuren gesehen wie haben die gräber
gesehen
wir haben mit sehr vielen augenzeugen
gesprochen und ich haben uns genau
geschildert was dort geschah und das ist
absolut unverständlich dass die
russische regierung das militär
sich weigert
zuzugeben dass es dort geschehen ist
nicht nur wir haben das dort beobachtet
auch journalisten aus der ganzen welt
haben die beweise gesehen und der beweis
ist ja offensichtlich für alle da ja
nicht nur nicht zugeben sondern putin
hat dem mutmaßlichen und in ihren augen
kann man das mutmasslich dann jetzt wohl
streichen kriegsverbrecher dafür ja auch
noch ausgezeichnet für alle die diesen
brutalen krieg verfolgen scheint es ja
bereits zahlreiche beweise für
kriegsverbrechen durch die russische
armee zu geben und dennoch ist das
sammeln von beweisen offensichtlich ja
auch viel komplizierter als viele von
uns denken was können sie uns über ihre
arbeit vor ort erzählen was genau machen
sie mit augenzeugen sprechen das habe
ich gerade schon vernommen
ermittlungen umfassen verschiedene
schritte erstens müssen wir augenzeugen
identifizieren die tatsächlich dabei
waren wir
sprechen mit ihnen und dann erfahren wir
aus erster hand was dort geschehen ist
und dann müssen wir natürlich belegen ob
das stimmt was sie uns erzählt haben wir
haben verschiedenen augenzeugen
gesprochen
wir haben mit anderen
mitarbeitern gesprochen von
medizinischen organisationen wir haben
mit denen gesprochen die die leichen
geborgen haben hängigen die tatsächlich
vor ort waren an den tatorten dann haben
wir unsere eigenen ermittlungen
durchgeführt wir haben die leichen
forensisch untersucht obduziert wir
haben die exponierung dieser körper
beobachtet wir haben blutproben
entnommen in manchen gebäuden und in
manchem massengräbern von butscher und
wir haben versucht forensische beweise
zu sammeln und fotos zusammen von dem
zeitpunkt wo diese verbrechen geschahen
und wir haben satellitenbilder
ausgewertet um wirklich beweisen zu
können dass die russischen truppen zu
diesem zeitpunkt auch da vor ort waren
als wir die körper gefunden haben wie
erleben sie denn die gespräche mit den
menschen die mit ihnen ja wahrscheinlich
dann sehr detailgenau nochmal durch
diese geschehen durch diese traumata
durchgehen müssen über den tod von
angehörigen nachbarn freunden sprechen
müssen
diese arbeit ist aus meiner sicht sehr
wertvoll für mich gespräche mit den
augen zeugen die diese traumatischen
erlebnisse erlebt haben und es ist sehr
wichtig ihnen zuzuhören und ihnen eine
stimme zu verleihen so dass ihre stimme
weltweit gehört wird so dass wir die
täter zur rechenschaft ziehen können und
ich hoffe dass wir in diesem kontext
auch diese rechenschaft erleben werden
ob das nun in den gerichten in der krone
sein wird oder in anderen gerichtshöfen
wie zum beispiel deutschland oder
weltweit für mich ist das natürlich eine
schwierige arbeit ich spreche mit den
familienmitgliedern über diese
schrecklichen details dennoch gibt es
mir hoffnung dass unsere arbeit sich
lohnt und dass wir richtung
rechenschaftspflicht gehen
ob sie sich nun wird werden dann
vielleicht auch noch mal gerichte zeigen
und entscheiden dass sie wichtig ist es
glaube ich jedem von uns hier klar darf
ich sie an der stelle fragen wie sie
eigentlich mit dieser situation umgehen
mit dem was sie hören mit dem was sie
sehen
wir sehen hier verschiedene arten von
missbrauch in der ukraine
das ist sehr niedergeschlagen seit
wochen beschäftige ich mich nun mit
diesem thema spreche mit verschiedenen
familien sie haben angehörige verloren
durch hinrichtungen menschen sind
verschwunden ich habe mit mitgliedern
gesprochen die ihre geliebten während
luft anschlägen verloren haben oder
wegen boden schweben
der verlust und das leiden in dieser
gemeinschaft ist tatsächlich
niederschmetternd
wie hoffnungsvoll sind sie denn dass die
beweise die sie in butter und auch
höchstwahrscheinlich dann noch an
anderen orten finden werden wir haben
heute von unserem korrespondenten gehört
der aus kiew zugeschaltet war dass es
weitere massengräber gibt die gefunden
worden sind wie hoffnungsvoll sind sie
denn dass es am ende wirklich zu einer
verurteilung der täter täterin kommt
bei uns mal die geschichte an das war in
der vergangenheit recht schwierig eine
verurteilung von tätern herbeizuführen
tätern die das internationale recht
völkerrecht verletzt haben und in diesem
konflikt haben wir eine einzigartige
möglichkeit das ist für uns vielleicht
die erste möglichkeit dass nicht nur der
internationale strafgerichtshof der ja
auch eine ermittlung in den ersten tagen
des russischen angriffskrieges
eingeleitet hat
tatsächlich eine möglichkeit hat ein
gerichtsverfahren herbei zu leiden
darüber hinaus gibt es zehn eu staaten
die ihre staatsanwaltschaft beauftragt
haben nicht sich hier die verbrechen
anzuschauen natürlich haben wir auch den
generalstaatsanwalt der kleine der sich
damit beschäftigt das ist eine
einzigartige möglichkeit dass wir
diejenigen die verantwortlich sind zur
rechenschaft ziehen können und das ist
eine einzigartige möglichkeit
welches wille dann vielen herzlichen
dank auch wenn es an der stelle schwer
fällt für ihre arbeit aber sie ist
einfach unfassbar wichtig und alles gute
für sie und für die menschen mit denen
sie zusammenarbeiten danke ihm sehr
denkt ihr herzlichen dank